how do you reach the people whose minds
you need to change listen that's in
terms of reaching the people whose minds
we need to change I've got a lot of
things that I do well but I'm not in
order that's good if you might do if
you've heard me read a speech it isn't a
pleasant experience so to reach them but
but what I think it's going to take to
reach the minds of people i think first
of all young people already care just go
to the university's young people care
and i think it is going to be very
difficult for any politician over time
to deny that climate change exists
because there's going to be so much
tangible evidence in terms of the
weather events that they're not going to
be able to do that i think so that
that's not my concern my concern is that
people will acknowledge that it exists
but won't be prepared to take the strong
measures we take me to take now to take
out an insurance policy to to protect
not only ourselves but our children and
our grandchildren from a very very
different world and what none of us
would want to live in